13 jahre chefredakteur des spiegel autor
des bestsellers der baader meinhof
komplex heute herausgeber der
tageszeitung die welt
eine der renommiertesten journalisten
des landes ist bei uns und ich freue
mich sehr über stefan aust herzlich
willkommen so für nichts persönliches
heraus sie haben in diesen tagen ihre
autobiografie ist eine zeitreise
vorgelegt über die wir natürlich später
noch ausführlich sprechen wollen
erlauben sie uns aber vielleicht vor
ganz kurz ein blick auf die aktuelle
politik zu werfen
an diesem wochenende findet die letzte
landtagswahl vor der bundestagswahl
statt glauben sie dass das auch am
stresstest für berlin sein könnte auch
jede wahl ist ein stresstest für berlin
und ich glaube man muss etwas ruhiger an
wahlen rangehen und ich glaube es ist
notwendig öfter mal wechsel zu haben
denn wenn wie in berlin im augenblick
wir mit derselben regierung oder mit
derselben kanzlerin mit wechselnde
koalition schon sehr viele jahre leben
und sie ja immer wieder auf irgendeine
weise eine neue koalition zusammen
gekriegt hat dann gewöhnt man sich so
ein bisschen das gefühl ab dafür dass
sich da auch mal was ändern könnte dann
denkt man diese regierung ist in stein
gemeißelt und bleibt so und deswegen hat
man sich nicht mehr daran gewöhnt dass
es ein wechsel geben könnte und ich
glaube es wäre schon ganz gut wenn man
mal irgendwann eine amtszeit begrenzung
einführte meistens haben wir jetzt ja
gesehen bei verschiedenen kanzlerschaft
wird es am ende nicht gerade besser auch
nicht für den entsprechenden kanzler
oder die kanzlerin bleiben wir noch mal
beim thema des ostens sie haben ja seit
der maueröffnung gerade mit spiegel tv
sehr intensiv die entwicklung begleitet
auch die letzten jahre natürlich immer
den osten sehr stark beobachtet wie
erklären sie sich die tatsache dass doch
relativ viele ostdeutsche offenbar sehr
unzufrieden sind und einige immer noch
sagen wir sind doch nur bürger zweiter
klasse
naja wenn man wenn man durch den den
osten also die die neuen bundesländer
fährt dann hat man wenn man die
infrastruktur ansieht dass ich bin jetzt
gerade aus dresden gekommen und da schon
häufig oben gefahren hat man den
eindruck sie zum teil besser als als im
westen
also wenn sie mal von von kassel nach
erfurt fahren denken sie nicht dass sie
vom westen im osten fahren sondern
umgekehrt
aber was man glaube ich nicht ganz außer
acht lassen darf
es werden viele positionen in
universitäten in gerichten in
fernsehsendern was weiß ich in
institutionen werden besetzt von leuten
die aus dem westen kommen und ich glaube
dass das feld auf ich kann das jetzt
nicht statistisch nachweisen aber ich
habe den eindruck dass das so ist und
ich glaube das ist so ein hut und schub
system richtet geht mal einer hin der
wird professor und wurde seinen buddies
aus dem westen
und irgendwie sehen die dann
komischerweise will mit dass hier von
wessis und ich glaube das geht den
leuten auf den wecker das ist das glaube
ich auffällig ist ja eigentlich auch das
fast sämtliche spitzenkandidaten für die
bundestagswahl auch aus dem westen
kommen ich glaube bis auf timo kubala
von der afd
haben sie das gefühl dass die leute das
im osten bemerken oder sehen dass das
merken die das ist gar keine frage und
dann stellen sich die frage ich meine
die merken natürlich nicht oder haben
nicht so auf dem schirm
dass viele leute aus dem osten den
westen gegangen sind da auch in firmen
karrieren gemacht haben also ich hab ja
selbst leute eingestellt bei spiegel tv
und die den wirklichen tollen job
gemacht haben schon vor jahren das
richtig dass sieht man natürlich nicht
so das heißt wenn die da sehen dann
sehen sie diejenigen die aus dem westen
zu ihnen gekommen sind aber nicht die
die aus dem osten in den westen gegangen
sind
aber ich glaube das feld auf und ich
glaube die die politik sollte ein
bisschen darauf achten dass vor allen
dingen in behörden und universitäten in
gerichten und so nicht zu viele leute
ständig aus dem westen die positionen
wie zugeschustert trinken ich glaube
dass wirklich ein problem
man gab es in den letzten tagen auch
eine ganze menge aufregung um einen satz
des ost-beauftragten herren wanderwitz
der in einem podcast sinngemäß gesagt
hat anteil der ostdeutschen sei eben
nicht in der demokratie angekommen wie
sehen sie das
also ich finde es ehrlich ist eine
ziemliche unverschämtheit also wenn ich
jetzt auf sie wäre würde ich mir das
nicht so gefallen nicht so gerne anhören
aber eines ist natürlich schon richtig
es ist richtig dass die art wie wir
denken hat etwas damit zu tun wo wir
herkommen wie wir aufgewachsen sind
in welchen schulen wie gewesen sind was
unsere lehrer gesagt haben und da spielt
ist natürlich schon eine rolle wenn
leute 40 jahre lang oder wie alt sie nun
auch immer sind in einem mehr oder
weniger totalitären sozialistischen
system aufgewachsen sind
in dem den sie nicht gelernt haben ihre
freiheitsrechte zu nutzen in denen sie
sich angepasst haben das hinterlässt
natürlich seine spuren das ist gar keine
frage aber 30 uhr über 30 jahre nach dem
mauerfall ist es schon erstaunlich dass
ist das erstaunlich und ich muss sagen
ich finde das auch keine besonders kluge
und auch keine richtige bemerkung aber
es ist keine frage dass wir natürlich
alle auf irgendeine weise von unserer
von unserer jugend und fand unserer zeit
geprägt sind dass das kann man ja gar
nicht über bord werfen und man hat so
ein bisschen den eindruck auch dadurch
dass sagen wir mal ja die afd es ja im
osten relativ stark muss man sagen das
hat glaube ich was damit zu tun dass es
dort nicht so eine scheu gibt wie im
westen bei denjenigen so die in den 60er
jahren aufgewachsen sind die sich ja
sehr viel mit dem dritten reich mit
hitler mit der schuld der väter und
großväter auseinandergesetzt haben und
deshalb eine eine ziemlich wenn man
sagen natürliche abwehrhaltung haben
in der ddr waren die immer auf der
richtigen seite und haben sich
vielleicht nicht ganz so damit damit
auseinandergesetzt wie na da die schuld
in der in der elterngeneration gewesen
ist
aber mir jetzt sehen dass die afg doch
im osten relativ stark ist jetzt nicht
die alle irgendwie als nazis bezeichnen
will das nicht mir jetzt veröffentlicht
dass dieser eindruck entsteht
okay wir bleiben wir bei der afg im
osten und schauen auf der anderen seite
mal in den westen da sind die grünen
inzwischen sehr stark haben sie das
gefühl dass das wieder sondern eine art
spaltung des landes irgendwie was
politische sichtweisen angeht ja ich
glaube schon
ich glaube dass die dass die unter
anderem deswegen sehr stark sind weil
sie sich möglichst weit von der realität
entfernt weil sich die realität nicht
mehr so genau zur kenntnis nehmen dass
sie ständig die welt retten wollen ohne
an die interessen der bevölkerung dieses
landes so direkt zu denken und und es
viele ideen gibt was man alles machen
müsste und wie groß man alles machen
müsste ohne zu sehen ob das überhaupt
realisierbar ist
sie sprechen jetzt von einzelnen zum
beispiel das ob naja der benzinpreis ist
natürlich je teurer das benzin wird
desto weniger ärmere leute können sich
das leisten nicht also sind diejenigen
die geld haben bevorzugt weil dann
möglicherweise auf der autobahn nicht so
viel verkehr ist also ich überspitzt
dass jetzt ein bisschen
aber das ist natürlich zum teil auch
wenn mal sagen die denkweise einer
verwöhnten gesellschaft sollen wir auf
annalena baerbock
es könnte ja durchaus sein dass sie mit
ihr die erste grüne bundeskanzlerin
bekommen in deutschland wir nehmen sie
denn frau berbalk so war
ach quatsch und bisher hat sich ja
eigentlich bei den wahlen im
herausgestellt dass die grünen lange
nicht so stark geworden sind wie sie
vorher den umfragen waren also es ist ja
sehr leicht sein um fragen zu sagen was
wollen sie wählen damit sie nicht
irgendwie in verdacht kommen was in die
eine oder andere richtung zu gehen
das ist immer das ist eher wie schick
und modern ob das nachher dann
tatsächlich wenn es wenn es bei leuten
um die schlichten fragen geht wie
bezahlen wir an die unseren
lebensunterhalt ich will bezahlen wir
unsere miete wie kommen wir irgendwie
mit dem auto oder mit der bahn
irgendwie ins büro wie ist das alles
also diese art von realität
ob sie dann die grünen wählen da bin ich
ein bisschen zweifel
nun müssen wir ein politikern zu gute
halten dass quasseln sozusagen wie sie
gerade eben gesagt haben zum geschäft
gehört das ist richtig und sicherlich
gibt es auch genügend gründe ich
vertrete jetzt einfach mal die andere
seite wenn wir sagen geworden
klimaschutzgesetz machen müssen wir
natürlich auch dazu bereit sein auf
irgendwelche dinge zu verzichten das ist
wohl auch vollkommen klar denke ich aber
bleiben wir mal bei der jetzigen
amtsinhaberin angela merkel mit der sie
sicher auch sehr intensiv beschäftigt
haben sie vom ersten tag oder am körper
am ersten tag genau was habt ihr denn so
fasziniert an frau merkel
ich hatte an frau merkel noch nie was
fasziniert aber mich hat auch an anderen
politikern eigentlich noch nie
irgendetwas fasziniert ich bin da immer
ein bisschen auf distanz gewesen und ich
kannte sie und und kannte sie auch schon
bevor sie bundeskanzlerin wurde
es gab ja auch mal vorwürfe dass wir
beim spiegel bei den wahlen die schröder
hervorgezogen hatten hatte ein bisschen
zu kritisch mit mit schröder umgegangen
sind und deswegen auch mit daran
sozusagen schuld waren das die kanzlerin
geworden ist das ist totaler blödsinn
diese schuld kann auch oskar lafontaine
auf sich ziehen weil er aus der spd
ausgegangen ist und die linkspartei
dahin gekommen ist und linkspartei
deshalb über 5 prozent gekommen ist und
deswegen das für die spd nicht gereicht
hat oder was weiß ich auch immer welche
konstellationen dann rolle spielen was
man vielleicht gar nicht mehr so im kopf
habt das hatte ich ehrlich gesagt auch
nicht mehr so richtig parat nachdem
schröder die wahlen vorgezogen hatte und
dann etwas schlechter aussah als die cdu
da hat er ja nur ein prozent weniger
da hätten die auch eine ampelkoalition
bilden können das hätte gereicht mit fdp
und grünen und der kette schröder war
der kanzler sein können und das ist in
wahrheit von der spd selbst verhindert
worden
naja schröder ist in der elefantenrunde
noch davon ausgegangen dass er
möglicherweise kanzler bleibt weil es ja
für eine ampel gereicht hätte ich habe
neulich mit ihm darüber gesprochen habe
ich verrate nicht was er gesagt hat
komme trotzdem nochmal zur angela merkel
zurück ich finde es doch erstaunlich
dass sie sagen irgendwie ist hat sie nie
großartig was fasziniert an ihr
gleichzeitig machen sie jetzt eine
fünfteilige doku serie über die frau
naja man muss ja nicht nur filme über
leute machen die einen faszinieren
also ich würde mal sagen die faszination
von politikern hat sich bei mir
insgesamt in grenzen ich glaube dass das
gerade staatschefs oder regierungschefs
wenn sie sehr lange im amt sind denn
dann machen sie sich geradezu selbst
sagen wir mal zum denkmal sie werden 1
oder die leute betrachten sie als eines
und merken gar nicht mehr dass das ist
auch nur ein mensch der die
regierungsgeschäfte hat und je länger
jemand dann in diesem amt ist desto
größer wird eigentlich die position und
verdeckt geradezu die person und
deswegen bin ich also ich bin mehr denn
je und immer mehr der meinung dass die
regelung wie sie die in amerika haben
nämlich ein amtszeit begrenzung auf zwei
legislaturperioden würde uns auch gut
tun gerade natürlich in einer in einer
verfassungs form wo der wo der kanzler
oder die kanzlerin ja von den parteien
gewählt wird also von den fraktionen im
parlament
und wenn wir nicht wie in amerika sagen
wir zwei parteien haben die sich
gelegentlich mal abwechseln sondern man
aus verschiedenen koalitionen immer eine
neue macht gruppierung zusammenstellen
kann
dann wird man ja irgendein regierungs
chef oder eine chefin überhaupt nicht
mehr los dann kann ja einmal mit mit
schwarz rot und haben wir mit schwarz
gelb und dann wieder mit schwarz rot und
dem vielleicht mit jamaika oder sonst
was also ich glaube und es ist dann
immer auch eine ganze gruppe die die
dort an der regierung an der macht ist
ich glaube ein bisschen mehr wechseln
könnte uns wirklich gut zupass kommen
und ist angela merkel aber seit vielen
jahren immer noch die beliebteste
politikerin im land würde das nicht dem
widersprechen dass man sagt die bürger
bekommen
die kanzlerin oder den kanzler die oder
der für sie war diese person ist das ist
das gegenargument aber ich glaube dass
die dass die menschen dazu tendieren den
gegen der denjenigen oder diejenige die
an der macht ist dann auch besonders
wert zu schätzen weil sie an der macht
sind als sie neigen schon dazu hinter
den mächtigen hinterher zu laufen und
ich also wie gesagt man kann das auch
anders sehen nämlich also aber ich nehme
mir das recht heraus zu sagen ich bin
wirklich der meinung ist es besser es
wäre besser eine amtstag begrenzung
einzuführen das ist ja die ganze ist
immer dieselbe gruppe dirigiert komisch
mal in welchen positionen herr altmaier
schon als minister war
sie habe in der letzten zeit auch sehr
häufig die rolle der medien in der
politischen berichterstattung kritisiert
warum nein habe ich nicht kritisiert ich
habe manche in mancher hinsicht andere
positionen und das hat etwas damit zu
tun wie ich aufgewachsen bin oder wie
ich wie ich in den journalismus gekommen
ich habe mich immer ich habe mir so
etwas scherzhaft gesagt als verspätetes
kind der aufklärung wir sehen das heißt
die funktion darin gesehen sowie im wie
auch sein dass man einen schönen satz
gesagt hat sagen was ist also das zu
beschreiben was ist und hab mich nicht
irgendwie als aktivist gesehen ich
deswegen habe ich auch nie um die
petition unterschrieben und bin keine
bürgerinitiative und dergleichen mehr
weil ich möchte wenn ich mich mit irgend
einem bestimmten thema beschäftige dass
ich mich sozusagen unvoreingenommen mit
dem thema beschäftigen das mag ja alles
falsch sagt man eine falsche
einschätzung haben aber ich möchte nicht
dass leute weil sie denken ich bin in
einer bestimmten partei oder bestimmten
gruppierung das sind von vornherein
wissen
sich zu einem bestimmten thema denke ich
mache mir jedes mal neu ein bild davon
ich kann mich erinnern
ich hab mal ich glaube auch dass
philippe vorher politiker wurde also
eine anwalt war hat mich mal gefragt ja
sag mal war sie mit ihm
wo stehen sie denn eigentlich politisch
nein da hatte ich gerade irgendwie
beiträge bei panorama gemacht über
berufsverbote für dkp mitglieder da ging
es ja um die lehre und die
lokomotivführer und dergleichen oder
briefträger und da habe ich gesagt
daraus wie ich jetzt zu einem solchen
thema stehe nun zu schließen dass die
dkp nadeln wäre völlig falsch
gucken sie sich die verschiedenen
beiträge an die ich machen dann können
sie sehen wie ich zu verschiedenen
beiträgen wurde zu verschiedenen themen
stehe aber ich werde nicht von
vornherein sagen wie ich sozusagen die
gesamt welt betrachte dann haben sie ja
lange für als links geltende medien
gearbeitet wie konkret sahen den spiegel
panorama und er wechselt zu springer ist
dann doch zum teil sehr kritisch beäugt
worden
haben sie sich verändert oder hat sich
springer verändert der spiegel hat sich
verändert
nein ich glaube ich also ich habe jetzt
gerade wenn man wenn man so wie ich das
gemacht habe ich mein ganzes jahr mit
der eigenen vergangenheit beschäftigt
und alte artikel sieht und sich briefe
anguckt und um sich haus mitteilung beim
spiegel ansieht ich und vielleicht ist
es auch gar nicht gar nicht besonders
gut wenn man sich nicht verändert hat
aber das ist ein bisschen viel bei ich
glaube brecht hat das mal gesagt nicht
so sagte account erreichte sich gar
nicht verändert
ich habe mich in den meisten positionen
habe ich mich nicht verändert und sie
können jetzt auch nicht konkret sagen
spiegel gleich sitzen da ist natürlich
schon ein großer unterschied gewesen und
ich bin hab bei konkret nach der schule
habe ich habe ich nicht deshalb
angefangen weil ich irgendwie so
besonders links gewesen bin und das ist
auch nicht so dass ich meinen dass sich
das hinterher irgendwie verändert habe
meine meine aussagen dazu hab da
angefangen weil der jüngere bruder von
vom herausgeber klaus rainer röhl mit
dem habe ich zusammen schülerzeitung
gemacht und dadurch kannte ich ulrike
meinhof und und und
klaus rainer röhl kannte ich schon als
ich noch zur schule ging
wir haben zu hause bei den eltern von
ruhe gesessen und haben uns panorama
beiträge von ulrike meinhof angesehen
und als ich fertig war mit dem abitur
hat er mich gefragt ob ich dann nicht
anfangen wollte ich wollte eigentlich
studieren ich wollte im grunde gesundes
langes praktikum oder sowas machen und
dann habe ich gleich richtig papier
arbeitet layout gemacht überschriften
gemacht und den laden so mehr oder
weniger gemanagt mit ihm alleine wir
hatten ja im grunde nur eine einzige
mitarbeiterin das war diese kriterien
und das waren einfach sehr interessante
zeiten und ich habe eine position damals
gehabt sie gesagt haben es ist gut dass
so eine zeitschrift wie konkret gibt und
ich finde für die in der freiheit eines
landes gehört es dazu dass es solche
publikationen gibt und es gab auch eine
menge artikel die bei konkret erschienen
sind mit denen ich mich ohne weiteres
identifizieren konnte ich war auch gegen
den vietnamkrieg und und verschiedene
andere punkte dagegen gegen alte nazis
in den gerichten oder schulen oder
universitäten
aber ich habe zb die die neigung die ddr
sich schön zu denken
die habe ich niemals mitgemacht für mich
war ein staat der seine bürger einsperrt
nicht diskutabel in keiner hinsicht und
und damit habe ich auch von vornherein
durchaus kontroverse positionen
vertreten als adenauer gestorben ist hat
die gemeinde immer gesagt jetzt ist ein
vorbild gestorben das war eine sauerei
so reaktionär war ich nicht was wahr
sich röder mal gesagt also sie ich war
mit dem immer sie sie werden nie den
standpunkt der arbeiterklasse einnehmen
sagt er dann ist das wohl so und bekam
ein lob hat man so von oben herab finde
ich etwas gesagt gesagt du bist doch
unpolitisch nicht also das habe ich dann
auch irgendwie so hingenommen und konnte
trotzdem ganz gut mit ihr
aber für mich war so die die grundlage
des denkens war eigentlich immer so der
begriff von freiheit
das war für mich das entscheidende und
da
wie sie von den von den drei kategorien
freiheit gleichheit brüderlichkeit ist
ja im grunde die erste nämlich die
freiheit bei den meisten heute so
langsam weggestorben jetzt sind wir
schon mittendrin in ihrer zeitreise und
damit auch bei ihrem buch sie haben
später in einer im nachhinein dann
aufsehenerregend aktionen die kinder von
ulrike meinhof aus sizilien gerettet die
so wie sie sagen die raf in ein guerilla
lager in palästina schicken wollte
mit welchen geschehen denken sie denn
heute an solche geschichten ist das noch
ganz lebendig ihnen was spielt das für
eine rolle für sie wenn sie diese
schildern
na ja das ist so lange her dass es schon
bald nicht mehr war es nicht aber es ist
wahr und die geschichte ist so gewesen
und ja ich bin noch mal runtergefahren
nach sizilien weil wir den hinweis
hatten wo die kinder waren und ich war
der ansicht man könnte nicht zulassen
dass die in dieses kinder geringer camp
geschickt werden und zwar das war ja
unmittelbar vor dem schwarzen september
als es da richtig richtig zwischen den
jordanier und palästinenser wirklich
anfängt richtig krieg zu werden
das könnte konnte man nicht verantworten
und wenn man die möglichkeit hatte die
da rauszuholen und davor zu bewahren
dann glaube ich hätte es im grunde fast
jeder gemacht haben haben sie noch
kontakt zu dem mann und ich so viel also
die legen die schmale aber nicht so
intensiv auch im fernsehen haben sich
viele akzente gesetzt über viele jahre
mit spiegel tv und es fiel auf dass sie
da einen ganz neuen moderationsstil
präsentiert haben sie waren immer sehr
klar sehr nüchtern damit unsere
zuschauer sich nochmal kurzes bild
machen können schauen wir uns noch mal
ganz kurz ihre erste anderer ration aus
dem jahr 1988 es zeugt von
geschichtsbewusstsein dass man sich in
schleswig holstein für die wahl
ausgerechnet den achten mai ausgesucht
hat guten abend meine damen und herren
ich begrüße sie zur ersten sendung von
spiegel tv
das war s dann bei spiegel tv guten
abend
das war die letzte das war die letzte
abmoderation aber ich würde mal sagen
von der machart sehr ähnlich kühl und
sachlich wie die
erste moderation springer chef döpfner
hat sie zu ihren siebzigsten geburtstag
als direkt und geradeaus und fast schon
empathie arm bezeichnet würden sie sagen
da hatte er recht
das erste direkt und geradeaus will ich
jetzt nicht bestätigen aber natürlich
stimmt ist empathie arm ist
wahrscheinlich auch richtig also ich hab
ich habe als ich das konzept für spiegel
tv gemacht das war eine halbe seid mir
nicht wahr dass und da habe ich mir auch
gedanken gemacht über die moderation ich
war ja vorher 15 jahre bei panorama darf
man nicht unterschätzen
und ich habe mir die politischen
magazine ja sehr genau angeguckt in der
zeit und schon in dem konzept für
spiegel tv stand drin
der moderator sollte nicht der
anklagende staatsanwalt wie klaus
bednarz bei monitor sein und auch nicht
parat wie franz alt sondern eher der
redakteur im studio der ruhig und
sachlich und vielleicht mit einem
kleinen sarkasmus
diddy diddy themen an sagt also dass das
war das konzept und ich habe den
redakteuren die beiträge gemacht haben
auch immer eines gesagt hat wir müssen
das nüchtern erzählen habe gesagt das
muss so sein glaub bloß nicht dass wir
heulen nicht denn in dem moment in dem
der in dem der moderator oder der
redakteur versucht irgendwie emotionen
zu wecken
dann liegt er irgendwie schon falsch der
der der soll in kriege ziehen oder zu
katastrophen seien fahren und und
darüber berichten und und er sollte sich
selbst mit seinen emotionen ziemlich
zurückhalten und so haben wir das die
ganze zeit gemacht und das war
allerdings die anweisung von augstein
nie lächeln die lachen
das war seine einzige anreise dann
gelassen
angst gucken wie buster keaton daran
habe ich mich gar nicht gelegen ist es
glaube ich ganz gut gelungen
dafür setzte und in der moderation bei
der moderation haben wir das so gemacht
auch bei ihrer zeitreise auch in dem
buch fällt auf dass sie relativ wenig
persönliches von sich geben sag ich
jetzt mal also ihre innerlich keiten
bleiben weitestgehend verhüllt auch wenn
sie unglaubliche geschichten natürlich
zu papier gebracht haben wir alle erlebt
haben den letzten jahrzehnten
warum ist das so fällt ihnen das
weiß ich nicht glaube ich glaube wenn
man wenn man berichterstatter ist dann
kann man sich selbst ein bisschen
zurücknehmen da geht es um die sache und
da geht es darum die zusammenhänge
einigermaßen darzustellen und möglichst
genau darzustellen und und die emotionen
die sollen dann ja wenn sie irgendwo
aufkommen der musste zuschauer sie
selber haben und da will ich den nicht
erzählen was sie zu füllen haben wo
allerdings dann doch die eine oder
andere emotionen meine ich zumindest
aufgelegt ist das wenn es im buch um
ihre familie geht und auch
beispielsweise um ihre pferde geht sie
haben ja ein gestüt und sind ein verein
gespielt gestüt ist ein riesengroßes
ding haben wir haben einen kleinen
zuchtbetrieb ein kleinen einen hof mit
ein paar pferden paar stunden und
manchmal gibt es mehr manchmal weniger
und das bedeutet dass sie geht er ihr
herz auf also der ist da der kühle
stefan andere kann ich sagen also meine
mutter ins krankenhaus kam und dann
kriegt er glaube die herzschrittmacher
oder irgend bypass gelegt dazu mich
angerufen hat gesagt ich muss jetzt ins
krankenhaus griechen bypass grabner
herzoperation damit gesagt recht das ja
eine gute nachrichten oder du hast ein
herz dann haben wir haben wir gemeinsam
darüber gelacht aber das war bei uns so
ein bisschen wir waren da so ein
bisschen cool insgesamt in der familie
auch wo wir schon jetzt gerade direkt
bei ihrer kindheit sehen sie sind ja an
der elbe aufgewachsen ihr ganzes leben
lang eigentlich auch in hamburg und in
nicht sehr weit gekommen
na ja sie haben extrem viele reisen
gemacht würde ich mal sagen kann man
alles in diesem buch nachlesen die
abitur und führerschein und das
bronzeabzeichen so dass ich an turnieren
teilnehmen darf und wir haben gesagt
obwohl diese ein bauernjunge ja na klar
meine nein mein vater hat also ist
vorzeitig vom vorm abitur von der schule
geflogen weil er dem dem lehrer mal also
buchstäblich als porto pi gefasst hat
und dieses papier ding dann auch runter
gerissen hat als er von der schule
geflogen und dann hat er eine
landwirtschaftliche lehre gemacht und
und ist dann 1900 ich glaube 24
ausgewandert nach amerika und war da war
15 jahre in kanada usa als als cowboy
als trapper hat beim beim bienenzüchter
wie an der hudson bay wieder arbeitet
ist in der schlechten zeit als als
arbeiter unterwegs gewesen oder hat sich
als die grosse arbeitslosigkeit
sein pferd gekauft es damit erwiderte
ein halbes jahr durch kanada geritten
und ist daneben 1939 im sommer mehr oder
weniger auf heimatbesuch zurückgekommen
und weil er noch im deutschen pass hatte
hatte sich nun umgehend im krieg wieder
gefunden
er hat sich soweit ich weiss nicht
freiwillig gemeldet aber wie gesagt
darüber hat man man hat man hat auch
wenig geredet kommt dabei raus habe ich
immer gesagt aber keine zeitung liest
und ich war nicht so besonders schlau
aber ja so war das und wir haben so
kleinen bauernhof dann also das heißt er
gehört ja nicht mein großvater ganz
kleines ding 15 hektar fünf oder sechs
kühe die vater jeden morgen fünf
gemolken hat und wir mussten mit
ausmisten einen kleinen trecker gefahren
winzigen kleinen und so und dann hatten
wir obstbäume und so was also das war
schon irgendwie etwas mickrig aber auf
der anderen seite hatte ich viel mit mit
arbeit an der frischen luft und bewegung
und und pferde hatten wir auch am anfang
dann waren sie wieder weg dann hatten
wir doch wieder welche und insofern habe
ich immer so eine beziehung zur
landwirtschaft gehabt und die liebe zu
pferden ist ihnen ja geblieben
ja ja das ist dann so geblieben also das
ist ja ja das ist so
eine mühsame angelegenheit aber es macht
viel spaß und wir haben dadurch uns am
wochenende der wandel nicht mehr auf
unserem hof sondern mit uns selbst und
ein anderes ding zugelegt und da waren
meine geschwister meine schwester meine
brüder waren am wochenende ende
eigentlich immer da und dann haben wir
sind wir gemeinsam ausgeritten haben die
stelle gemacht und saubergemacht und und
die zäune gebaut und haben uns dann da
eigentlich
wir haben wir zusammen am tisch gesetzt
beim abendessen und sagte mal haben wir
die jugend geredet und dann hat meine
mutter gesagt ja so schlechte jugend
hatte die jedoch gar nicht da waren wir
alle irgendwie 30 jahren und dann hat
man eine schwester gesagt ja und so
lange aber das hilft natürlich für sie
wenn sie wenn sie viel arbeiten und sich
viel mit politik und anderen themen
beschäftigen deren mann am wochenende da
rauszukommen und sich aufs pferd zu
setzen durch den wald zu reiten
und frische luft zu haben und
gelegentlich vom pferd zu vereine wieder
aufzusteigen
das hilft schon wieder aufstehen ist ja
im jahr 20 auslaufen was sie durchaus
auch in den letzten jahren immer wieder
fabriziert haben wie man da lesen kann
ich will ja noch zu einem anderen buch
kommen dass sie in diesen tagen raus
gebracht haben und zwar ein buch über
bob dylan in dem prominente wie wolfgang
niedecken ursula von der leyen otto
schily patti smith und also eine endlose
reihe an wirklich großen köpfen dieser
zeit sage ich jetzt mal über ihr
verhältnis zu bob dylan geschrieben
haben und die seine musik sehen wie
sehen sie denn bob dylan das bedeutet
eine für sie na ja er ist eigentlich
derjenige jeweils aus meiner erfahrung
meiner sicht der die die gedanken einer
ganzen generation und und an der ganzen
immer jugendbewegung sah man im
weitesten sinne ziemlich auf den punkt
gebracht hat in den in verschiedenen
auch widersprüchlichen songs die ja in
sich auch zum teil widersprüchlich sind
und er repräsentiert so sagen wir das
antiautoritäre der bewegung der 60er
jahre hat sich auch selbst nie angepasst
ich bin hat sich nie irgendwie zum zum
vorzeigeobjekt irgendwie von bestimmten
politischen bewegungen gemacht hat dann
wieder kehrtwendung eingelegt hat sich
damit den leuten noch irgendwie erzürnt
oder hat denen den rücken zugewandt
das fand ich sehr interessant also wir
haben wir haben für dieses buch ja eine
reihe interviews gemacht und haben auch
sind zu ein paar konzerten gemeinsam mit
denjenigen gegangen die behinderte
hinterher interviewt haben also zum
beispiel zu dem konzert in berlin sind
wir gewesen mit ursula von der leyen und
otto schily war sowieso ein richtig
interessanter abend
das war wirklich ein weg na gut wir
haben ja die interviews gemacht mal hier
und da stehen ja auch in dem buch drin
aber otto schily hat auch fotos gemacht
was er eigentlich nicht durfte aber ich
habe die erlaubnis das zu sagen sonst
hätte ich nicht gesagt
das war wirklich ein interessanter abend
weil wir dann die sind ja die eine
ursula von der leyen das deutlich jünger
als ich und chili ist noch ein stück
älter als ich peter schneider wir
übrigens auch mit also der
schriftsteller ein sehr guter alter
freund von mir
und und dann haben wir so diese zeit
revue passieren lassen und das was
interessant war die sind die die neueren
konzerte von bob dylan aber schon im
grunde seit jahren sind ja so dass man
die stücke gar nicht erkennt sie kommen
dahin und dann später irgendwas müssen
die technisch und ziemlich genau kennen
um irgendwas zu merken was das
eigentlich ist was er gerade vorträgt
bis auf einen einzigen song am anfang
und aigen ein stück gleich ganz am
anfang zwei oder dritte stück wie sydney
biologen vorbei und ich kenne diese
texte ziemlich auswendig und ich bin ich
bin ganz sicher dass er das so gespielt
hat das alles verstehen und alle wissen
wie biologen vor
das heißt es ich bin es nicht auf den
ihr hier wartet und da hat er deutlich
gemacht er geht seinen eigenen weg und
erwartet nicht dass ich das tue was ihr
von mir erwartet und das war für mich
immer besonders interessant ihre
interviewgäste in diesem buch müssen
fast alle einen satz vervollständigen
zum ende ihrer jeweiligen kapitel da
bitte ich sie jetzt auch den zu
vervollständigen der satz heißt ein
leben ohne bob dylan ist vorstellbar
aber das wäre furchtbar lang für mich
gewesen ja welcher seiner songs würden
sie sagen passt im moment dann am besten
zu ihnen zu mir
der mann darf man darf nicht immer alles
von einem von einem erwarten und man
darf auch nicht erwarten dass sich leute
anpassen an das was gerade so zeitgemäß
ist und dafür finde ich es auch richtig
mal zu sagen was ich denke jetzt mal
anders darüber so und ich lasse mir auch
meine eigene meine eigene position nicht
nehmen und ich lasse mich auch nicht für
irgendwas instrumentalisieren
auch wenn es sagen wir die beste und
wichtigste sache der welt ist also oder
auch kleine sachen ich habe neulich zwar
ganz witzig ich mache immer in der welt
am sonntag in hamburg teil
macht der der chefredakteur der hatten
der hamburger ausgabe der welt am
sonntag macht immer so drei fragen drei
antworten mit mir
wir unterhalten uns jeden freitag ruft
mich jeden freitag gegen mittag an und
sagt so ich habe jetzt folgende themen
und stellen also drei fragen so und und
da ging s
letzte oder vorletzte woche um gender
sternchen
so auch eines ihrer lieblings ich hab'
ich habe viele lieblingsthemen aber ich
halte es für so bekloppt hätte ich war
neulich wenn ich das noch mal eben
schlecht ab beim ndr in der sendung und
habe ich vorher so gewartet bis es
losging und dann legt er eine broschüre
vom ndr so beschrieb sowie der in der er
ist und wie organisiert ist und da war
die position so eine passage und für so
groß habe ich ab fotografiert was macht
der intendant
aber das war politisch korrekt mit
gender sternchen
wenn sie das sehen was macht der
intendant bzw
die intendantin wenn er/sie punkt punkt
wenn sie das sich angucken dann merken
sie was für ein totaler blödsinn das ist
aber ich wollte auch in anderen punkten
ist sodann dann schreibt mir eine eine
leserin aufgrund meiner man drei sätze
darüber ja sie findet dass auch und
eigentlich würde sie gern eine petition
dagegen verfassen
ob ich die nicht unterschreiben könnte
habe ich mir zurückgeschrieben freut
mich sehr dass sie das interessant
fanden was ich gesagt habe
aber ich unterschreibe grundsätzlich
überhaupt nichts das mache ich
grundsätzlich nicht davon aus vielen
dank für das gespräch
[Musik]